my friends they aren't even pretending
anymore that they don't want more
violence they're threatening it openly
they're telling us
you know we might have to do more
violent stuff i'm about to play video
for you a former trump strategist and a
former breitbart propagandist steve
bannon
steve bannon says
we aren't going to have 4 thousand shock
troops ready to go
we're going to have 20 000 shock troops
ready to go
so that we can take control of this
country
they aren't even hiding it anymore let's
take a look at the video this is from uh
steve bannon's program
uh the war room
on real america's voice listen to this
the opposition particularly the
opposition elite and all their sword
boys and everything in silicon valley
media it's not a big part of the
population and they understand that they
understand it
the thing they fear
is the righteous ignignation
of the working class
in this country
and now they're seeing it and that's why
they're in meltdown the story i gave
this talk to these appointees and here's
what i said we're winning big in 2022
we're going to win big in 2024 we need
to get ready now
right we control this country we got to
start acting like it
and one way we're going to act like it
we're not going to have 4 000 ready to
go we're going to have 20 000 ready to
go and we're going to pick the 4 000
best and the most ready in every single
department
and that's when we really start to
deconstruct the administrative state
that's talking afc packing they're
always trying to destroy no no no no
we're trying to get an fda worse
shock troops on standby we control this
country
we have to start acting like it
and uh as zach petrizo reported
joe ben uh steve bannon
continued by talking about the
importance of spiritual warfare
to his audience
to defeat the enemy this is exactly what
the fbi should be investigating this
this is exactly the type of thing
that will rile people up
and get them ready to do horrible things
again
he's essentially calling for
a um
so i mean is militia even the right word
he's calling for
a people to be on standby to forcibly
take slash remain in power
now
i do want to sort of turn this around
and take the take it as an opportunity
to make a different point
if there aren't more
see if there aren't more and more
serious consequences for the january 6
rioters
that will also implicitly encourage them
to try again and to go crazier
this guy was the chief strategist for
the president of the united states
this is not ending anytime soon it's
been less than a year since trump helped
by
senators members of congress
the uh
maga people
people like steve bannon they encouraged
they incited
they pushed
for an attempt
to try to take the election from the guy
who actually won it who was joe biden
now
some of the dupes some of the patsies
that's really what they are
they've faced repercussions to some
degree
a couple have been sentenced some are in
the middle of trials we talked earlier
about the mother and son who were
arrested
but none of the people who instigated it
in congress has lost the seat now we
haven't had elections yet i understand
that we'll see if they lose seats but
the point is it's not clear whether they
will really
have and suffer electoral consequences
for their inciting for the fomenting of
what happened on january 6. so you know
we saw the lone wolf recently who tried
to burn down a democratic office in
texas
things like that as long as the right
continues to at a at a structural level
push this type of violent rhetoric
uh they're going to continue uh through
this kind of stochastic terrorism that
we've talked about before
creating these individual incidents the
individuals may face consequences some
may not some may plead out we don't know
yet
but are they really lone wolves when you
have this entire partisan apparatus
right-wing media apparatus a strong
contingent of republicans in the house
and senate when they're encouraging it
are they really even lone wolves anymore
even if the the physical act is one they
carry out by themselves as far as we
know
uh there's this entire apparatus kind of
vaguely encouraging this behavior if not
specifically now some are asking how is
what steve bannon is saying not
treasonous treason is is sort of
specific in terms of its legal
definition article 3 section 3 of the
constitution
which says treason against the u.s shall
consist only in levying war against them
or in adhering to their enemies giving
them aid and comfort the key is that
treason means going against the us and
americans as a whole
this is all kind of tinged enough about
going against a political party and a
movement
that it's probably not sufficient to
meet the definition of treason it's more
like a
a seditious conspiracy to overthrow
the the particular government that there
is or something like that um
but it doesn't make it any more morally
acceptable let's make that uh completely
clear so
we're going to see more of this action
in real life because we're continuing to
see more of the rhetoric on right-wing
media
and you know going back to my earlier
segment on russell brand without
straight up being anti-vaxx and russell
brand probably isn't anti-vaxx
he has kind of threaded a line
that is asking the right questions as
they love to say
to push people
to become anti-vaxx on their own
if they're not already and if and if
they are already it just kind of
encourages them and ingrains them in
those beliefs
this is very similar with what we're
seeing with uh tucker calling about a
real insurrection might be warranted
steve bannon talking about 20 000 shock
troops and the like this is real stuff
and it has real consequences in the real
world
one of our sponsors is four sigmatic the
company best known for their delicious
mushroom coffee four sigmatics mushroom
coffee is organic fair trade single
origin arabica coffee with both lion's
mane and chaga mushrooms chaga mushrooms
have actually been shown to have
potential in supporting the immune
system in peer-reviewed studies i've
been drinking four sigmatic coffee a lot
lately it actually doesn't taste
anything like mushrooms it just tastes
like any delicious coffee but it's
really easy on my stomach doesn't give
me any jittery feeling or a midday crash
and they have over 20 000 five-star
reviews and best of all if you don't
love it you'll get 100
of your money back because they stand
behind their product you've got nothing
to lose by giving it a try
four sigmatic is giving my audience up
to 40 off and free shipping when you go
to
4sigmatic.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video